it's
no they use a spray
okay folks I'm going to get started
um I know next week is spring break and
you probably have big plans for the
spring break I hope finishing evaluation
is one of those plans so know just a
prod in case you haven't started because
once you come back like only a week
before you turn the end of that week you
come back is when you turn in your DCF
and two days after that is the the
second quiz so things start to pile up
so just just a prad um today I'm going
to try to complete our discussion of
story and numbers and I'm not actually
going to Value companies fully if you
notice I haven't valued a single company
all the way through in class done in the
valuation the way but I want to talk
about valuing companies fully and in
fact tomorrow's valuation of the week in
case you feel inclined to do it it's
going to be my Tesla valuation because
it's a fascinating company whatever you
think about it it's fascinating in terms
of stories and numbers how you know
stories can drive numbers and how
stories can change and they can break
and they can know so it's a perfect
example of a company to work so today as
I said we're going to talk about the the
specifics of valuation and and and
actually value companies but let's do
some starting analysis as you start to
Value companies you value a company and
you come up with a number
yes let's
see let's see if that's because
something else is on let me turn turn it
down a little bit maybe that'll help is
that better okay so maybe the sound is
set too high so let's say you finish
valuing a company you come up with the
value for the company and you have the
stock price out there right and the
value is different from the price so I'm
going to ask you a question about what
do you conclude next is it that you're
right and the market is
wrong that could be one right it' be
you're wrong and the market is right
now but leave open the possibility that
you're going to be there right because
the first time you value a company the
second time it's probably better to
start with the assumption that you're
wrong and the market is right in which
case what are you going to do you're
going to revisit your numbers and I'm
going to leave quotes around the word
revisit your numbers you're going to
revisit your growth rate revisit your
discount rate and you won't stop
revisiting the numbers till what happens
the value matches the price let it go
don't fight it because it's exactly what
you do when you start that presumption
is it possible you're both
wrong absolutely in which case it's
screwed right not necessarily as long as
you're less wrong than the other side
you're wrong in the right
direction you definitely can't be both
right right because there's only one
number out there but this is something
you will face up to once you finish your
valuation so think about it little early
some of you have already turned your
valuations I've returned them all about
seven or eight so if you send them now
you'll get almost instantaneous feedback
within 15 or 30 minutes you'll get the
valuation back because it's really a no
I'm I'm doing it on touch which is I'm
not pushing you on the number being
wrong it's about internal
consistency here's my second question
let's say you decide to value a high
growth company and some of you valuing
high growth companies you discounted the
cash flow and let's say you decided to
do cash flows to equity which is an
unusual choice it's not a choice I'm
pushing you toward but let's say you
discount cash flows to equity back at
the cost of equity and you come up with
an equity value of 100 million the
number of number of shares outstanding
is 10
million but in your cash flows you're
estimating negative cash flows in future
years and you expect to issue 2 and a
half million more shares we'll talk
about the process of doing that so
you've done a DCF value of your company
with negative cash flows in there you've
got the present value of 100 million you
got 10 million actual shares but two and
a half million more shares you will have
to issue in future years my question is
purely mechanical one to get my value
per share do I divide by the actual
shares outstanding the 10 million by the
12 A5 million that includes F future
Share
account or is this is the answer
somewhere in the middle what do you
think I you want to try do we divide by
actual shares fully diluted number of
shares so I think it's the is answer
netive let me play Devil's Advocate I'm
an equity research analyst but we're
going to issue more shares why aren't
you counting it
in already because the negative cash
flows already incorporate the effect of
delution if you do intrinsic value right
this is a huge pain that you've removed
from yourself right because to estimate
the 2 and a half million additional
shares in future years what do I have to
do how do I know how many shares I'm
going to issue I have to take my
negative cash flows estimate what share
price I will issue them and you can
already see the circular logic you're
going to be trapped in if you do
intrinsic value right your negative cash
flows are already Incorporated in the
present value because your present value
is lower because of that those negative
cash flows that is the delution effect
already built
it and it's tough to get across actually
work with numbers you can see the effect
play out so we'll come back and talk
when we talk about young companies
you're going to see this play
out so now I want to go back to
storytelling and especially those of you
working on your valuations now you're
wrestling with this question of
Storytelling last session I talked about
the first step in the process learning
enough about the business that you can
tell a story and the Second Step was you
stopped and made sure the story passed
the 3p test is it possible is it
plausible is it prob and I took my Uber
story and maybe I was too light on
myself but I think I passed all three
tests I can give you a basis for my
story Urban Car Service Company already
doing it pulling new people in the Bay
Area they've doubled the size of the car
market they' pulled it off with local
networking benefits even by 2014 you
could see this process evolving you
didn't have hundreds of right sharing
companies you saw very quickly that you
were
consolidating keep doing what they're
doing so they're already doing it
nothing to justify and I did mention
that I could have told a bigger
story what's the advantage of telling a
bigger
story you get a bigger number right as a
Founder you're tone between the urge to
tell a really big story because you get
a really high price or telling a more
compact story and you first just let me
tell the biggest story I can I'll get
the highest number I can but there's a
problem that follows right you collect
the number you told this really big
story first you got to justify The Story
So Far More defense to play and then
once you've told the big story and got
my my my Capital what do you have to do
you have to deliver on that story you've
made your business a much more difficult
business to run because you promise
people things that might be out of your
reach so you tell the story you make
sure it passes the 3p test and here I'm
going to give you a note of caution
especially if you're an investor once in
in a while you will run into a story
that you so want to be
true that you never you don't even ask
questions I'll tell you the the
components of the story the Storyteller
is this incredibly charismatic person
you really like usually the
founder second they're telling a story
about disrupting a business you've never
ever
like and I I can name quite a
few and third this is there the icing on
the cake while they're disrupting the
business they're going to make the world
a better
place come on don't you want the story
to be true let me tell you a story and
you tell me whether you want the story
to be true it's about a
19-year-old who drops out of Stanford
who does that you know how difficult it
is to get
in gets in and drops out to start a
business another tech geek starting
another software business here's where
the story takes an interesting turn it's
not another 19-year-old male dropping
out to start a software business it's a
19yearold female dropping out of
Stanford to start a blood testing
business now come on do you guys like
the blood testing
business in the US if you think about
the experience it's the exact opposite
of a good experience right here's how it
will begin you will call Quest labs to
make an appointment we have an opening 6
months from now no I could be dead by
then something sooner 6: a.m. 6 weeks
from now you take it what choice do you
have you show up at 6:00 a.m. they make
you wait why because they
can two hours later the door opens and
the nurse comes out she looks like nurse
ratchet from one Floor Over the Cuckoo's
Nest say come on in knees knocking you
walk in there are two buckets next to it
so what are those for your
blood why just in case Dracula shows up
how much of my blood do you need they
extract half your blood anemic you crawl
out of the place you go back to your car
you drive home you don't hear from the
place for like four
weeks so you call them say I want the
results of my blood test we can't give
them to you why privacy it's my blood
test we've given them to your
doctor talk to your doctor you call your
doctor you go through this process again
6 months from now 6 weeks from now 600
a.m. sure wait 2 hours you walk in your
doctor's obviously got your blood test
he's looking very troubled while he
looks at the blood
test so you wait and after about 10 or
15 minutes of terrifying you he says
there's nothing wrong with you you leave
don't keep a sigh of relief yet because
the ultimate indignity is in the mail
two weeks later right what do you get a
bill from Quest Labs saying your
insurance did not cover seven of your 15
blood test will cost you
$1,500 come on don't you want this
business to be disrupted everybody did
so here's what the 19 year-olds come up
with she's going to take two drops of
your blood not two buckets in a
nanotainer this already sounds very 21st
century buckets are so 15th
century and in 45 minutes she's going to
run 32 different tests on your blood
some of which you don't even know what
the test is but it's another test the
whole thing is going to cost you 50 and
she's going to email you the results
it's almost like she's caught up with
time and along the way you know she what
she's going to do she's going to give
away this blood test for free to parts
of the world where people can't afford
blood test and all the lives you can
save come on don't you want if you were
making a Hollywood movie this would be
such an uplifting
movie this is of course not a madeup
story this is the true story of
Elizabeth Holmes
and teros did people get excited boy did
people get excited by the middle of
2015 Venture capitals were pricing the
company use the word value should be
pricing company at 9 billion and some of
the biggest names in Venture capit on
the list Ted Raper was on the
list 9 billion V cap get excited really
quickly true the Cleveland Clinic was
touting teros as the next big thing in
blood testing one of the leading Health
entities and Walgreens was planning to
add a teros lab into every
Walgreens you can see collectively if
you'd ask me in the middle of 2015 what
I thought about Theos my answer would
have been I don't know much about the
company but given the 9 billion and
Cleveland Clinic and Walgreens there
must be something there I assume that
somebody somewhere along the way would
have asked the question you have a blood
testing company what's a big question
you want asked and answer before you
throw money
in does your blood test work right this
is not some fuzzy thing I assume
somebody would have asked a question but
I was wrong nobody seemed to have asked
a question because in October of 2015 a
Wall Street Journal reporter decides to
ask the question and the answers were
actually in the public domain because
you have to file with the Ft FDA and get
approved he went to the FDA and said
teros on its web page is claiming that
this test works on 30 now how many of
these 32 tests have they been approved
for the fds they approved for one and he
said what about the other 31 and the FDA
said the results are a little
noisy he's saying what's a noisy blood
test trust me you don't want to see one
comes back and says you might be dying
or you might not don't worry about it
blood test you want Precision right and
roughly you might have a lot of blood
sugar or you might not we can't really
tell you could be in a diabetic coma
before the whole thing gets
resolved in the next 6 months the entire
company unraveled the 9 billion became
zero Elizabeth Holmes by the time you
get a six months out has been banned
from the blood testing business for 3
years and there were criminal cases
already accumulating across which
ultimately got the final sentence came
down last year she actually moved to San
Diego used to keep running into her in
the know when you went for a walk I mean
I don't know what she was doing maybe
she thought it was a foreign country she
wouldn't be extradited but turned out to
be part of the
us she's now in jail I don't know what
the sentence is but when it happened I
remember people saying how can you not
ask this question so I wrote a post then
which you can still read where said it's
easy in hindsight to say why wouldn't I
have asked the question but I remember
when Elizabeth Holmes came to New York
in the middle of 2015 to give a
celebrity
talk there like thousand people in the
audience people had brought their
daughters along so they could see 29
year old
first know billionaire starts a business
you know
essentially I said if you'd been at that
meeting in New York you surrounded by
people who brought their six-year-old
8-year-old
daughters would you have had the courage
to get up and ask the question does your
blood test
work you have felt like the guy who shot
Bambi's mother I've always felt for that
guy the hunter the start of the movie
Bambi's mother Falls
over I mean you were killing
dreams basically right there it's easy
in hindsight to say how come nobody
asked the question you caught up in the
moment and everybody else is kind of
caught up in that this is the most
amazing thing ever it's really difficult
to ask a question that's why I used the
the The Emperor's New Clothes as kind of
the perfect way think about why people
don't ask these questions till it's too
late the process worked out again with
Wei work when when Wei work came out
same process I remember looking at we
work's IPO and their basic business
model is what leasing out buildings for
30 or 40 years often in the most
expensive parts of the city and then
subleasing them for 3 months 3 weeks 6
weeks it's never worked in real estate
before right why not what's the problem
with that
model you got a duration mismatch made
in hell you're one recession away from
going under because you have a recession
everybody Le you still have the lease
payments and now remember reading the
400 page prospectus what what what gave
we work it's heft n i mean Goldman Sachs
estimated that it should go for 95
billion so how do you come up with the
95 billion what was it that made we work
so attractive to investors when it came
when it went
public who is the biggest investor we
work soft bank and by extension Master
son and M saw in 2019 was viewed as a
Visionary
genius you know what the last round that
soft Bank investment we work at was 47
billion here's how Goldman sachs's mind
works Mas on priced we work at 47
billion he's a really smart guy he must
have got a deal let's double it they
must have made a mistake in two times
47 come up roughly 95 billion and you
reverse engineer the whole
thing if you get a chance go back and
look at the Wei work Prospect is it's
still on my web page because when I it
came out I tried to valuate 412
pages I was convinced when I started
reading it that they must have found
some secret source to deal with the
duration mismatch I mean it's staring
you in the face mostly 4 12 Pages later
no mention of duration
mismatch and the whole
thing looked like it was either in
denial you were not or that they just
were assuming you didn't
care the case of we work the whole thing
kind of spun out to go back in the other
direction right what did Wei workor do
on its Prospect around the IPO that you
think caus the whole thing to unravel
because two two months later if you
remember the IPO was pulled from the
market and the only reason reason it
ended up with the number is somebody
came in and said we'll pay at least 8
billion you know who that somebody
was soft
Bank why because they want to write it
down to zero this is a business you look
at say how can you ever think that this
is a good
idea the only problem is the the
arrogance that we work showed at the
time of the prospectus you read that
prospectus and it was jaw-dropping in
terms of some of the Clauses you read
in a normal company the publicly traded
company when a CEO is
incapacitated what's the process you go
through the board of directors gets
together they look at candidates they
pick one right you know the weiwo
prospective said would happen if Adam
Newman was
incapacitated that Rebecca Newman his
wife would pick a successor what is this
the French royal
family but the fact that they thought
they could get this through tells you
how arrogant they were in terms of
thinking we're special I mean what's I
mean what was Adam Newman's pedigree for
starting wew work how did he become
famous does anybody know he gave a tedex
talk in 2012 about the importance of
we
community and it's strange when one of
the most narcissistic people people on
the face of the Earth uses the word we
but that's often the context in which we
that became we Works he took that Ted X
do and he made it into this company that
then he got masan to buy in and that's
how when you look at runaway stories
they melt out usually the narrator has
feet of clay new discovery in the weeks
after the Wei work filing the New York
Times reported about the strange
behavior that Adam Newman had around
headquarters he insists did that people
not wear
shoes you know basically walked around
bare feet and other people had to walk
around bare feet you said this is not
what rational people
do and eventually that that once you
once you start to question the
Storyteller then everything else starts
to spin out of control because there's
nothing else here beside the story
yes also think about you could argue
that there is a but have youever driven
a
Tesla there is is it a fairly unique car
is it I mean we got to give M the credit
he he took a business that there had
never been a competitor in a century
right look at every person who tried to
enter the automobile business in the
20th century read the story of DeLorean
or watch the documentary right every
person who tried to disrupt this
business what happened they crashed into
their assembly line wall of not being
able to invest now so I remember when
Elon Musk started Tesla you know what
the rest of the Legacy auto company said
about his
chances they laughed they said how will
a startup electric car company ever
change the way we do business 16 years
later what's every leg Legacy auto
company trying to
do become an electric car company so
this is not Adam Newman right there is
and think the same thing with SpaceX why
what's you know what's the reason SpaceX
has been able to expand as much as it
does has it cost them half as much to
get a satellite out in the sky than any
comparator out there I mean there are
people trying I mean that's the reason
SpaceX is taken on so clearly there is
substance here has he you know is he got
that that narrator aspect absolutely the
problem is he keeps spinning tails that
essentially take Tesla it's not just an
electric car company yes you know when I
posted my Tesla valuation you're
guaranteed to hear from both sides and
the people said what about Optimus you
know what they're talking about right
the robot business and this is
constantly the issue with Tesla you said
look as an electric car company it's not
worth a trillion they said that's not it
it's automated driving they seem to have
moved on from automated driving now it's
robots and you got to give must credit
in terms of he's able to build a story
out there get enough people believing in
that that
story and that might be one thing that's
been missing for the last 14 months he's
not been telling stories about Tesla
he's been telling stories about other
things and people are saying when will
you come back and tell me another story
we need a story now a story that goes
beyond robot so you know there is a
component of that narat that people
invest in the company because they
believed in him so I think that's enough
yeah in fact I know I put a number on it
right I put 150 on it because and I like
Tesla and I like Elon Musk I you know as
as a Visionary I think you need people
like that to change businesses so
actually when I got the 150 I wish it
have been 3 350 right because in a sense
I I bought the stock last year when it
went to
170 know but I want it in my portfolio
because it is a company that's changing
the automotive business it's changing
already it's not changing it has changed
it in fact if you ask me 50 years from
now what will be the three automobile
companies standing I think Tesla and byd
will be two of the
three the third might be one of the
Legacy auto companies I don't know which
one it's not even a question of can
Daimler become no Daimler is never going
to be the leading electric car company
BMW I can I will be willing to bet that
no Legacy auto company will be in the
top two globally you know
why because when when you buy a electric
car you're not buying a car you're
buying an electronic device think of it
as a very
expensive smartphone with a big battery
that you can drive
around then ask yourself a question
would you buy a
smartphone made by I don't know
RCA now just putting the name on it you
say hey that they can't make this
they're all 20 you see already if I make
a diimler electric car versus some you
know Lucid electric car I'm already
saying dier this so 20th century they
make cars I want an electronic device
and I think that's what the Legacy auto
companies were missing is they thought
their brand name that they developed
from the automobile business would
travel into the electric car business
and it's not doing it but if you have
Visionary spin out it usually starts
with the narrator kind of spinning off
and that's your wor with Tesla is your
lead Storyteller is now become a
political hot rod right it's never good
for a company where half the market will
not buy you because of your politics I
don't care which side of the Divide
you're on and then the then you realize
the stories at war with the numbers that
the person's been telling a story and
with teros that was obvious because the
numbers there basically was the it
doesn't work and then you have a bad
business model on top of it the whole
thing blows up so when you tell stories
tell stories but be careful about how
far those stories will take take a
little tangent here and talk about big
markets what's the current big Market
what's the dream that people are holding
out AI right is this the first big
Market no in my lifetime I've seen big
markets come and go some have been
fleeting but China 25 years ago big
Market social media 15 years ago big
Market PC is 40 years ago big market so
let's say you're looking at a big market
and you're an
entrepreneur and you want to start a
business to be part of that big market
right could be the India story or AI
pick whichever big Market you're more
comfortable with now I want to step back
and ask you something about in general
about entrepreneurs do entrepreneurs
tend to be overconfident people or
different
people what do you think it's almost by
definition to start a
business actuaries are very very for
entrepreneurs because they work through
the odds and said you know what the odds
are against me so to begin with your so
you're an overconfident person looking
at a big business you think you could
conquer it you go out and seek money
from Venture capitalists Julian venture
capitalist overconfident people or
different
people they always think they can pick
the winners right what does I tell you
about them I am special I know who the
winners are so you've got an
overconfident entrepreneur who attracts
overconfident V sees you have a cluster
right and you're looking at a big Market
what does that mean when I say you're
overconfident that you overestimate your
Chan of succeeding overestimating
revenues or and there are hundred other
clusters just like yours all over
Silicon Valley or wherever your
Tech each of them thinks they're special
each is overconfident and each values a
business based on the overconfident
let's play this through so if I take
business by business and take the
valuation that are going to emerge from
every business or the pricing if you
wanted and I add the numbers up what is
the collection of my numbers the
aggregation of my numbers going to look
like it's going to be too high right
eventually the truth comes out reality
is an ugly beast it RS its head and
there's a recognition that we can't all
succeed so what do you have you have a
correction and then people wag their
fingers that this is what's wrong with
you guys this is why we will'll never do
it again you've heard that
before we'll never do that
again it's a feature not a bug of big
markets and trust me you will do it
again and I want you to do it again
sounds like a strange thing so I wrote a
piece saying what's so bad about bubbles
you know the amount of backlash I got on
that one what do you mean what's wrong
with bubbles bubbles
burst but do they change the way we look
that do boom and bust yeah change the
way we live the social media boom and
bus change the way we live AI there will
be a boom and there will be a
bus change the way we
live fact the question ask I ended that
post saying would you want to live in a
world run by actuaries I don't don't
want to keep picking on actuaries but
think of actuaries as everything being
driven by probabilities and expectation
we' still be in
CES this fire thing is said you know
what it's not been fully tested yet one
of these days we'll get out
there thank God we don't live in a word
run by act or the flip side of this is
if you want change if you want creation
you got to live with chaos I still
remember the regulator of the Singapore
stock market you know I was in Singapore
a couple years ago he said can I come
over and talk to you was have some you
know have a question to ask you and he
comes over and he says we want to make
Singapore's Equity markets more
exciting track more and I said I can
tell you how but you got to be willing
to live with a little chaos you know
what Singapore thinks about chaos
right the Singapore Market will not ever
be the hub for exciting entrepreneurial
growth because that always comes with
chaos and disturbance it's a part of the
noise so I call this is the big Market
delusion right you have a big market and
I used the the online advertising
business about 10 years ago illustrate
how this plays out I took the online
advertising business I took publicly
traded companies SP company like Google
and Facebook got almost all of the
revenues from online advertising I took
their market caps and I backed out from
the market cap what the revenues would
have to be 10 years from now to break
even so I used the solver a function in
Excel to solve for that then I added up
all all of the advertising revenues I
got 10 years out for each of the
companies and I came up with a total
that was 50% larger than the overall
advertising Market all advertising put
together can't happen but you can see
how this gets built up because even if
you think about how equity research
analysts value companies they value the
company but you can see the same
phenomenon in a lesser way play out
there right they picked a company they
think it's going to be the winner they
build the numbers but there are 50 other
analysts picking 50 other companies
working their way
through big Market delusion is part one
final example and then we'll leave this
alone so this is about 10 years 11 years
talking about Tesla might as well go
back to Tesla it this is Tesla very
early in its life as around the time I
did my first valuation of Tesla where I
valued as a luxury automobile business
cuz that's where I thought it was going
so I did my valuation and Tesla's always
had the good or the bad fortune of being
Fallen back equity research analysts who
are not analysts in the traditional
sense that Tesla
Advocates so this is valuation done by
one of the biggest names out there in
terms of equity research tracking Tesla
I won't name the person but you could
probably trace him back if you want so
he you know he puts out an equity
research report around the same time
that I value Tesla and his value is six
times higher than mine and I'm curious
so I open up his uh report keep looking
for why his number is so much higher I
look at his projections of revenues you
know Tesla was selling 24,000 cars there
and he projected that would sell 1.1
million in 15 years
plausible we give you a rough sense last
year there were 80 million plus cars
sold so 1 million is clearly within the
range of what do you think somebody Su
so I said okay in fact his estimated
number of cars was was actually a little
lower than mine
then I said maybe he's assuming software
company margins so I look at the margins
his abar margin was actually a little
lower than mine now I'm completely
befuddled he's uh projecting at less car
sold than I am he's projecting slightly
lower margins how is his value six times
higher so when he looked at his
unlevered free cash flow which is free
cash flow to the firm I prefer the free
cash of the firm and he also had what he
called net income which is really like
he had an after after tax operating
income when you have after tax operating
income in free cash loow spreadsheet and
you add them up you basically get two
numbers the difference between the two
numbers is what you're reinvesting right
so I took the next 15 years of after tax
operate income in is stable the next 15
years of free cash loan is stable and I
looked at the difference and there was
almost none in fact collectively over
the next 15 years he was reinvesting
almost
nothing we have a problem you know the
problem is in 2013 Tesla had one Factory
in Fremont with a capacity on a really
good day to make 250,000
cars you're selling 1.1 million
cars there's a gap here right like call
the analyst he was in an airport on his
way to California maybe to worship at a
Tesla Shrine I don't know what he was
going to do and I said he said look I
want to talk about some the numbers in
your equity research report and he said
I can't talk about them I said why not
he said well I I don't actually work on
the numbers I have a team that works on
the numbers I said you had a team turn
out this DCF yeah I said team of six I
said okay can I call you next week he
said yeah we'll all be together and then
he says you're not going to write about
this on your blog or anything right I
said not for the moment but after next
week all bets are off so I call the guy
the entire team is gathered together
lead analyst comes on and said so I said
what do you do he says you know he
describ basically he schoes he talks to
people different Industries people
company people Chief schoer so I said
what about your second in command he
says I'm the secondary schoer I go with
this guy and and the third guy's a
backup Schmo or one of the two guys I
said who in this group does something
other than just
Schmo they point to this 24 year old kid
that hired out of warten two years he's
the
guy nice way to throw somebody under the
bus so I lead him through the kid's
pretty smart he gets it very
quickly basic Bally that you know I said
what happened he said it slipped my mind
I said what slipped your mind he said I
took the capex and depreciation the most
recent year and the most recent year
Tesla had not done built much factories
I just projected them out and
effectively I built in zero close to
zero reinvestment over
time and I said do you think you have a
problem he said yeah of course you know
we can't make 1.1 million cars when your
capacity is 250,000 but we don't there's
no easy way for us to let the market
know that screwed up we can't go back
and say it slip my mind he said do you
have any suggestions I said I do and you
might not like them I said have you ever
watched this movie willly Wonka's
chocolate
factory he said no but one of the older
analysts had have you seen that movie
Jee Wilder in it one of my favorite
movies of all time I still remember
watching that movie when as a much much
younger person and coming out of the
movie with a singular question there's
only one Factory that Willy Wonka had
it's a very
badly engineered Factory with like
chocolate Rivers running through it and
I remember asking question how does that
one Factory produce all these chocolates
that Wily Wonka sells around the globe
the answer is actually in the movie
these little munchkins called Oompa
loomas you go go on to Google and type
in Oompa Loompas and as they dance
chocolates come flying out of the
factory so I said here's what you need
to do put out a news release
that Tesla has fired all of its Freemont
workers and replaced them with Ooma
loomas the problem's gone I call these
Ooma Loompa valuation you building big
growth no reinvestment unless you Ooma
loomas this is not going to fill itself
so the next time you pick up a
DCF I want you to put it through the
test right take it through because it's
right there in front of you you have the
tools to take it
apart so now let me talk about
converting storage numbers in the case
of uber if you remember my total my
story was of an urban car service
company that will attract new people
into the business right so where do I
start my story by estimating how big the
urban car service Market is you know how
much of a nightmare that was this was to
estimate in
2013 who dominated this business before
Uber came
along taxi cab companies around and
they're all private owned so here's what
I had to do to get the size there was no
no number out there I went through City
by City New York City has a taxi and
limousine commission they can tell you
how much taxi caps collectively
generated as revenues last year I did
this for New York I did for Tokyo I did
it for London I got to about my 50th
City and I was really tired but then I
was at 50 billion you know what I did I
doubled
it and I said I'm too tired to go beyond
50 cities the total size of the urban
car service Market is 100 billion to
show you how you should never trust
Google search 6 months later I get on
and say maybe somebody has a good
estimate say size of the urban car
service Market on Google guess what pops
up as the number one find de modin
estimates it at 100 billion do you guys
know what de modin did to estimate it I
won't take you into the kitchen but this
wasn't some know specific estimate based
on special information but I had to
start somewhere billion in total
revenues that market had been growing at
about 2% it was a really slow growth
Market but what was the second part of
my story to attract new people into the
business right since I'm using 2% I use
6% who's it drawing in people like my
son and my niece who would never take a
taxi cap come into the
business third if you remember I said
Uber has local networking benefits and
you probably said who cares in my story
what can happen you can have 10 right
sharing companies around the world
dominating different parts what does
that mean your market share is not going
to be 40 50% it's going to be closer to
10% I gave them a 10% market share even
as a successful company what do they do
connect drivers with customers that's a
lowcost business you're an intermediary
I gave them a 40% margin and to grow
what does Uber have to do close to
nothing I still remember the way they
added Deli to the list of cities they
hired one guy put him in a hotel room
they didn't want to pay for an office
and he went around signing up drivers to
sign for Uber cost them almost nothing
to grow the way it shows up is I gave
them $5 of revenues for every dollar of
capital a huge amount of Revenue that's
twice the average for a typical Service
Company in the
US and finally are they are they were
there risky company in
2000 big money losing company you know
how I computed the cost Capital by doing
none of the things we went through five
sessions doing bottom of a cost of debt
debt ratio instead I went to my
histogram of cost of capital for
companies and I went to the 90th
percent when you're Val young companies
this is not the place you want to be
spending immense amount of time
estimating a debt ratio doing a b it's
going to do absolutely nothing for you
and it's going to shift over time I gave
them a high cost of capital and is there
a chance they could just still fail at
least look looking at their
numbers yeah they're a company with $1.5
billion in losses hasn't figured out how
to make money the Venture Capital stops
they're done the only thing they have
going for them is they're too big to
fail for Venture Capital you see what I
mean by that you've written it up to 17
billion the last thing you want to do is
write it down to zero so there's going
to be greater Temptation for venture
capitalist to bring in more Capital just
to keep them going so I gave them a 10%
failure rate my story has become numbers
the valuation kind of flows right out of
it because once I put Revenue growth
margin three investment cost of capital
think of my Ginsu spreadsheet I've got
the numbers the valuation comes out
looks like a spreadsheet but every
number in the spreadsheet reflects my
story right if you ask me why my revenue
is 3.6 billion in your 10 it's because
Uber is an urban car service company
with local networking
benefits why my margin 40% because they
an intermediary why the reinvest so
little because they don't own the cards
every number there if you point it and
say why is that number what it is my
answer is going to be some part of my
story
other well I have the 10% I have the
3.6% so basically all you do is go from
3.6 to 10 right the the end numbers
basically are the numbers that matter so
if you disagree with me on year two I'm
going to give you your two you want your
three you can take that too you give me
your 10 I control this narrative
so the value that I got was 6 billion
was June 8 The Wall Street Journal
article that I told you triggered me on
this came out on June 3rd so the end of
the week I put this up it's like 3:15 in
the afternoon Friday afternoon 10
minutes later maybe 15 minutes later I
get a call from a Wall Street Journal
reporter she must just been waiting at a
desk for this post to come through she
said I noticed you Valu Uber I said
thank you for
noticing she said I also noticed you
attach a value of 6 billion I said very
observant she said you do know that
venture capital is a value the company
at 17 billion I almost corrected her you
know what the correction would have been
the price companies don't value them but
she's a journalist I cut her some slack
I said
yeah she said how do you explain the 17
billion I said I didn't pay it I don't
have to I have never felt the urge to
explain what other people pay you know
how much frustration this has saved me
in my life
because it's amazing how much time
people spend trying to explain what
other people do what business is it of
yours they're overpaying let them
overpay this finger wagging that goes on
of this is crazy this is shallow it
doesn't do anything for you and they're
going to do whatever they want she said
are you telling me they're wrong I said
I'm telling you nothing of the sort I'm
saying I have a story a value that comes
from the story and an action that comes
from that value Maybe maybe they have a
bigger story you need to talk to
them the way I think about valuation is
I have my valuation my numbers my
action know after I put the Tesla
valuation up I get a bunch of emails
saying you why you encouraging people to
sell short and
Tesla did I say anything about other I
said look I take you know this is what's
going to drive my decision the
architecture for you to disagree with
what I've done is right there so you
think Tesla is going to make money on
Optimus add a fourth line item create a
revenue and see if you can get up to 500
600 800 whatever you
want but the essence of a story is
essentially it gives you a number that
drives your
actions and finally talked about keeping
the feedback loop open the case of test
in the case of uber I was very fortunate
because after I put this post up on June
8th over the weekend I get calls from
four different places the first was a
site called 538.com you heard of 538
Nate silver used to be pollster for the
New York Times so for it's for it's a
statistics Geek
site it it was owned by ABC they just
shut it down in fact a couple of weeks
ago but at that time it was a thriving
Standalone site and they said can we run
your post because a lot of our readers
are numbers people and appeal I said be
my I guess with the entire post
valuation rent there the second place I
heard from was the Forbes blog who reads
the Forbes blog I think 75 year olds
with flip phones it's a really oldtime
value investing crowd they take the same
post same valuation run it through the
third place I got called was Tech crunch
what a tech crunch it's a digital
magazine which caters to Silicon valys
read by you know software people VCS
they said hey we like to run this
because many of our people are
interested and I said go ahead same post
same valuation and the final place it
ran was a site called The Ride sharing
guy I think it's still around was run by
a guy called Harry Campbell who wrote
for Uber and lift drivers Prime audience
there millions of those and he said can
I run this our Uber drivers will be very
interested I said go ahead same post so
Monday morning all four sites run it and
I start hearing from people in all four
from the 538.com it here's the kind of
question I get I noticed you used to 12%
cost of capital but in your histogram
because I'd also put the histogram into
my post at the 90th percentile the cost
to cap was
11.97% why did you use
12% so why I leave my spreadsheets open
I said why don't you go into the
spreadsheet change the 12% cost of
capital
11.97% and see what happens 5 minutes
later I get a very sheepish response
saying nothing happen happen I could see
why you did what you did nothing much
learned from second decimal point
questioning but that's what numbers
people essentially go to on the Forbes
blog they absolutely loved it they paded
me on the back they said this is how
tech people should value companies zero
useful feedback I skipped over very
quickly then I went to the tech crunch
site these guys absolutely hated it
their response is how dare you value one
of ours with your D.C
F we don't do that in Silicon
Valley so you get this bunch of
responses half of them were in pure
insults some of which I didn't even
quite get one said you DCF guy that was
the entire insult saying that is that a
good thing is that a bad thing I don't
know right it wasn't meant as a
compliment I think but I couldn't read
the subtext the other half started with
an inser you
idiot let me tell you how surge pricing
works at Uber and you know what I
learned if I got past the insult I'm not
a tech person I don't know what the
infrastructure is that allows a right
sharing company get an advantage and I
learned some very interesting things
about the technological components but I
had to get past the
inser and then I heard from people on
the right sharing BL and I learned
things about Uber that I would never
have learned talking to the top
management a driver in La wrote to me
and says I'm an Uber driver in La I used
to drive for until 3 months ago Uber
paid me $3,000 to switch now Lyft is
offering me 5,000 to switch back I feel
like a free agent without a
contract and this is how he ended he
said I wouldn't be surprised if all of
this money they're spending they end up
with more than seven or 8% not the 20%
they claim to investors five years later
Uber leaks that they contribution margin
in big
cities is 7 to 8% I almost wrote to them
saying Oh uba driver in La told me that
5 years
ago but this whole process for me came
to fruition about 3 or 4 weeks after I
finish this post I'm sitting in Munich
Airport waiting for a connecting flight
and it's delayed I start checking my
email and there is an email from a guy
called Bill Gurley heard of Bill partner
at Benchmark Capital Benchmark Capital
was one of the first VCS to invest in
Uber they invested a billion dollar
pricing bill was on the board of
directors of uber rumored to be the
person close to Travis gacn those of you
watch the was it Netflix that had the
Uber thing he's he's a lead character in
it so there's somebody playing Bill
obviously but let me ask you an easy
question does Bill gley know more about
Uber than I do
absolutely so I open the email and
here's how it begins I read your post on
Uber and I did not like it glad we got
that out of the way I've read my written
my own post to counter your post blog
post to blog post Warfare very 2 first
century and he said I've said some mean
things about you I just wanted to let
you know sincerely
bill I close the email I an hour and a
half left my flight guess where I go I
go to Bill's blog it's called above the
crowd the guyy 6t 6 in it's above the
crowd and here's the lead article it's
still on Google you can find it never
goes away it says demod misses by a mile
get it Uber Mrs by my my GPS is not
working I got the sub text there and
then he took issue with every part of my
story he said Uber is not a Car Service
Company it's a logistics company notice
how words of consequences by using the
word logistics he's already expanded
businesses car service moving
delivery he said it's not just Urban
it's going to be everywhere he gave
examples of suburban and Rural services
and finally he said it's going to take
cities like New York and London where
it's already dominant here's what we're
going to do we're going to connect with
credit card companies and Airlines so if
you make a reservation to fly from New
York to Jakarta United right below your
reservation there'll be a boxes do you
want an Uber car waiting for you when
you get there a very clever way of
taking local networking benefits and
making them Global networking benefits I
was fascinated along the way he said
some mean things about me but I have a
thick skin he say this deod has never
taken an Uber it was a lie I've taken i'
taken one
Uber but one is more than zero but
basically you know and you know I
finished the post and then I write to
him and I say I'm still sitting in
Munich Airport I say you've told a big
story for UB would you like me to put a
number on your story he said what are
you talking about I said these are all
stories I can make it he said be my
guest so here's what I did I took my
valuation of uber and changed two things
remember the total Market 100 billion
for urban I made it 300 billion moving
in delivery triples the market remember
the 10% market share local networking
benefits if he's right there'll be only
two or three right sharing companies
Domina the world I gave Uber a 40%
market share you change those numbers
the value you get is 53 billion I sent
this to Bill and I said do you like this
more he said a
lot and he said oh by the way that 20%
share is probably going to slip away and
I almost told him the Uber driver in La
told me this already but that was an
input in my spreadsheet I changed the 20
to 10 and came up with the value of 29
billion he's saying how can the same
company be worth 6 billion 29 and 53
well depends on how the story is framed
doesn't mean they're all right doesn't
mean they're all plausible but you can
see how differences can play out so over
the rest of the year I hear from people
saying I don't like your total Market I
don't like your market share I don't
like this finally I said look this is my
story my value my
decision but let's make it your story if
you ever been in a builder bear store in
a mall they're freaky little places
basically here's how they work you know
you go in if especially you have a
six-year-old 8-year-old you walk in and
they give you a piece of skin and over
the next 30 minutes your six-year-old
make one of the ugliest Bears know and
then they do this very sneaky thing they
would come up to you and say you don't
have to buy that bear but if you do
it'll cost you
$75 I guarantee you not leaving that
store with your six-year-old without
that bear so I stole from that idea and
made a build your own valuation of uber
so at every stage let people pick their
own story is it Uber is it a Mobility a
logistics a car Serv so essentially you
pick your business you pick whe you have
local you know Global or non networking
benefits and at the end of the process I
came up with valuations reflecting the
story choices you see that last column
what does that tell you people who read
this post say this is why there's no
point in doing DCF you can justify any
number that's not the way I see it in
young companies when you disagree on
value it's not because your growth rate
is different from mine it's because
you're telling a different story and I'm
going to probe what's your story why
because I want to steal some of your
story if it makes sense and bring it
into my story so as you look at these
these numbers they reflect different
stories and different values not all of
them are equally
plausible you've told a story you got
the inputs you got a value you say okay
I'm done can you story
break what what happened to
che che is a homework company took off
at a $2 billion market cap just a couple
of years ago now down to close to zero
why what does check do you're a ninth
grader stuck on an algebra prom you call
check there somebody who helps you
through charges it's like an Uber for
for PE for students media I mean the
uberization of the world is now complete
everything is you're an
intermediate it became a $2 billion
value why did the value collapse what
broke
them have you asking chpt what the you
could get a hypo if all you're getting
is very basic descriptions of what needs
to be done hey you know what AI can do
that you don't have to pay somebody you
don't need an intermediary that's the
first company we've seen break that AI
completely break there will be others
along the
way so that's a story break and with
young farmer companies this should be a
test a stage in the process Blockbuster
drug but basically it doesn't work you
pull it off story breaks that's the most
extreme stories can sometimes shift
which means your basic story stays the
same but you add a new market you
increase your growth a little margins
might improve I've been telling the same
story for Apple for the last 15 years
it's a SmartPhone company which has been
the greatest cash machine in history I
still tell the same story but you had a
little service business you so it's a
shift with it or stories can sometimes
change when a company does something you
did not expect
expected but a new business actually
opens up Microsoft story shifted
dramatically when the cloud business
took roots and took off until then the
story I was telling was of a two- hit
wonder that couldn't figure out a way to
come up with a new product stories can
break which is bad news if you like
stability right there are people who
believe that intrinsic value once you
get it it's Timeless already you can see
stories can change stories can shift and
your value could shift and what can
cause stories to change well obviously
it can be earnings
reports but it can be something
completely unrelated
numbers I'll give you an example and
this will finish my Uber story my
biggest change in my Uber story happened
about a year and a half after I wrote
this post I went back home to visit my
mother who lives in Chennai which is
part of India which is incredibly
conservative in terms of it's about 20
years behind everything else happening
in the country so 7 5y- old conservative
South Indian woman so I get home and she
says you know let's go somewhere you
know she names the destination I don't
even know where it is and I say okay say
I'm going to call the car and I'm
expecting you to do the 75y Old South
room which is open the window driver
bring out the car instead she starts
hitting a
smartphone first I'm surprised she has a
smartphone said Mom what are you doing
she says I'm calling for a car on Uber I
said you you subber she says all the
time I said I can't come with you I've
got to got to go back and revalue the
company you see why that 2 to 6%
increase that I got what did I assume
that people like my son 25 20 would be
coming in you've got a 75 year old woman
who's never taken a taxi cab in a life
wouldn't even dream of doing
it kind of change my entire perspective
on what the potential Market would be is
the Tipping Point for your story that
was my Tipping Point right so when you
think about stories everything is
feedback right when you buy a Tesla and
you're walking and you you bought Tesla
the stock and you're walking down the
street and you see somebody keying a
Tesla you should feel the urge to go
back as I have to revalue the company
this is something I did not have in my
story so stories can change and I think
that's makes them fun because it means
you're not just driven by the Numbers
you're constant looking for feedback
that's why I said Tesla is going to be
this experiment where you can see your
story shift on a day-to-day hour by hour
basis makes it terrify if you want
stability we wanted stability you
wouldn't be looking Tesla in the first
place so now let's talk about valuing
companies I'm going to show you a bunch
of valuations and to save myself some
time in terms of numbers that will show
up in every one of these companies
because they spare out of time you're
going to see an equity risk premium so
I'm going to give you some perspective
on where that number comes from before
1998 and there might be one company I'm
showing you where the value comes from
before 1998 I used to use a 5 and a
half% premium for mature markets and not
change it very
much between 1998 and September 2008 I
used an implied risk premum but it's
pretty stable around 4% you're going to
see a lot of 4% then of course you have
the 2008 crisis the whole thing blows
apart and I started doing premiums on a
monthly basis any valuation you see post
2008 you're going to see the implied
Equity risk premium as of that month so
I'm using exactly the same process still
but the numbers obviously will shift
over time and with each of these
companies that I'm going to Value I'm
going to go through that structure of
here here's the company I some of these
companies if you're not familiar I'll
tell you what they do I'll frame my
story and then you're going to see the
valuation now you're going to be bor
stiff if I go through every line I in
every valuation so in each valuation I'm
going to focus on what I think is
interesting and different about that
valuation so let's start
easy let's talk about stocks that look
like bonds what does that mean they pay
a big dividend then low growth this is
the Ben gram kind of stock right this is
the stock that you know so the company
I'm going to pick to value is ConEd what
does ConEd do all these lights are on
right now because con's supplying the
power right it is a regulated Monopoly
and already my story is getting
Fray if I just stopped with Monopoly
what do you get pricing power you could
talk about what but this is a regulated
Monopoly regula what sense it's
regulated in terms of what it can do
connet can't go buy AI stuff or invest
in software the nature of it business
it's got to Supply Power it can do
whatever helps you supply that power
where's the regulation
it's given the Monopoly but it to set
prices it has to go in front of a
Regulatory Commission the commission
tells them whether they can raise rates
or they have to give and what do what is
a commission base it on whether you can
raise
rates you're thinking too rationally
they will look at inflation but this is
in the rental commission right they look
at the returns you make as a company and
this is actually one of the first places
where the capm actually became a
tangible number because you could come
up with the cost of equity and you High
experts to tell you what it is let's say
it's 8% you make a 12% return Equity you
go in front of the Regulatory Commission
and say like a price hike the commission
says looks like you're making too much
money
already so come back to us when you so
it becomes so you can already see that
this is a very constrained
valuation and regulated utilities are
the mothers of all dividend payers they
pay dividends like essentially because
investors who invest in them want
dividends they're old older they need
the
income so already you can see the story
Being Framed it's a regulated Monopoly
serving a state where the demand for
power is not going to go up 10 15% might
be differently you're in a mountain
state or maybe a Florida or you here
you're not you're talking about slow
growth paying a big dividend and already
you can see where I'm going when you pay
a big dividend the question you always
have to ask is are you paying too much
are you paying the right amount how do
you check that
you estimate the potential dividend the
free cash equity and here's the first
thing I looked at how much they paid in
dividends they paid 73% of their
earnings already you can see this is not
going to be a high growth company and if
you look at the free cash or Equity it's
very close to Dividend so I'm going to
be okay using the dividend discount
model in terms of not overvaluing
undervaluing the company so it looks
like a mature company in terms of how
much cash it returns I did stop and see
what kind of growth do they have and
remember this is a
company very much in steady state their
retention ratio is 27% the return on
Equity is
7.7% and their expected growth you take
the product of those is 2.1% is it a
growth they can sustain forever well
it's well below the risk free rate so I
feel pretty comfortable assuming so it's
a big dividend paying company in mature
growth this one final stop I wanted to
make I didn't want to lock in a cost of
equity that' be incompatible with the
mature
company mature companies have cost of
equity pretty close to the market
average as a regulated Monopoly it's
probably going to be lower because you
got a guaranteed Market in the pricing
so I gave them a bait of 08 and a cost
of equity notice the return Equity is
roughly equal to the cost of equity and
it's almost by regulation they're going
to see that pressure to keep going so
I've got a mature stable growth dividend
paying company how do you value a mature
stable growth dividend you use the
oldest of all discounted cash flow
models a garden growth model a dividend
discount model I took the expected
dividends next year which is 232 this
year's dividends growing at 2.1% and
divided by the cost of equity minus the
growth rate and I can see some of you
saying I should have picked con to value
for my project you'd be done in like
five minutes right the value per share
that I got was
$423 and the stock was trading at
4076 slightly under value remember the
start of the class said what do you do
when the value that you get is different
from the price one question you can ask
is what is the market assuming that
might be different from what I'm
assuming in this case the market might
be assuming slightly lower growth right
is there a way I can solve for it
absolutely and that's basically what
we're going to do next but before we do
that there's one extension that I want
to point you to when you do a discounted
cash flow valuation that might help you
when you do a discounted cash flow
valuation of a company no matter which
model you use the value per share you
get is as of today you compare to the
price today the reason I'm emphasizing
it most equity research reports if you
look at them don't tell you the value
today they give you a Target
price one year from now is there a way
you can take your value per share today
this in the case of um ConEd which is
4230 and make it into a Target price a
year from now and I'm going to give you
some ammunition you have a cost of
equity I can tell you how much dividends
they pay what do you do Jacob
I like the grow a second time on the top
so take 4230 grow it at 7.7% that's the
total number but then that would be your
price if there were no dividends right
remember you get that seven subtract the
dividend from that you're going to get
an expected price of like $44 and 30 C
your s at equity research analyst you
put that as a Target price
2431 and don't show them what you did
because they said that's all it took
make it sound like you did some
mysterious
analysis the stock is actually Trading
at 4076 one way to think about an
undervalued stock is if you buy it at
4076 and it goes to where you said it
was going to go you're going to make
instead of 7.7% 12% 133% 14% you're
earning more than your cost of equity
you can take your DCF value make it
Target price one year from now could you
could you do Target prices two years
from now yes you can repeat this process
you can try to blow the Daylights out
and give me Target price for the next 10
years it's just an extension and if you
buy a stock that's if you tell me a
stock is fairly value and people
sometimes miss this you're actually
saying the stock will go up next year
fairly value doesn't mean the stock is
going to stay flat it is going to go up
at the cost of equity and if you have a
money losing company or a non-dividend
paying company that can be a pretty
substantial increase on a year-to-year
basis so any questions on converting DCF
value into a Target price yes Sima
cost of equity as the growth rate I'm
sorry it's not because that's if
something is fairly valued that's what
you can expect to earn on that's the
definition of the cost of equity so it's
not that you're using it as a growth
rate but if I want to earn a
7.7% return and I pay 4230 I'm going to
take the 4230 and grow it but the reason
I'm taking dividends out is my total
return will take price appreciation as
well as c as well as dividend so once
the stock is fairly valued that's what
you can expect to earn as a return in
that stock
capture risk again right we've done that
4230 it's already there it's risk is
also the expected return riskiest stocks
you should expect to see more price
appreciation but it's coming from the
higher
risk second company I'm going to Value
3M what does 3M do lots of boring things
that make a lot of money I always Marvel
at those Post-it notes there should be a
special corn in the Nobel price winners
or the guy who invented posted notes
it's a commercial genius
right you know how much money 3M makes
on posted notes you can get them in
different colors different sizes little
tabs and they've just expanded the
idea so this was a valuation I did on
September 12th of
2008 the
Friday the Friday before a weekend where
Barclays announced I'm sorry Leman
announced they were trouble and they
were looking at a this is the Friday
before the crisis start and the reason
I'm going to do this valuation to show
what happens to value of a company but
none of the numbers might change but a
week later you're looking at a very
different
Marketplace so I did my first valuation
and I didn't see the crisis coming I'll
be quite honest was Friday morning I
wanted to Value 3M why I have no idea I
told a very boring story a story of a
company that doesn't reinvest much
reinvest only 30% % but has a great
return invested Capital that pattern on
the Post-it note keeps competition
out that gives you a growth rate of 7
and half% not over the top but this is a
mature company 7 and half% growth and at
the end of your five I put them into
stable growth with the growth rate of 3%
so it's a very standard easy valuation a
two-stage valuation where I'm using
sustainable growth and I'm assuming I
live in a nice developed Market where
bad things don't happen overnight
I came up with the value prare of 8355
stock was trading at 70 so ask me the
question you know the question you have
to ask is to figure out whether I
actually believe my own
valuation did I buy I wanted to but I
was too lazy I had do on Monday morning
best decision ever procrastination
actually paid out because Monday morning
what do we wake up to a crisis of
historic proportions
6 weeks later I decid to revisit the 3M
valuation no new earnings reports had
come out the numbers were exactly the
same but the world I was valuing the
company and had shifted under me
right so what what had happened those
six weeks first markets had
collapsed and the second is the economy
looked like it might be rolling into a
recession so same company same base year
numbers nothing Chang the base year here
are the changes I made first notice my
risk premiums for both my debt the
rating didn't change but the default
spread for that rating increase and the
equity risk you remember that graph of
what happened in 2008 the equity risk
had been 4% it jumped to
6% you hold everything else constant
already you're going to see a knock down
in value from that I did get a little
more conservative about my estimated
growth rate because you're heading into
a recession you're not going to be able
to deliver the same kind of returns
slightly lower growth higher cost of
capital I did bring in the lower t- bond
rate that's one of the few benefits you
get is that the t- bond rate dropped the
value per share that I got was $61 down
from $84 am I surprised it dropped by
that much not after a crisis like this
one the stock price was actually
57 this time I did buy the shares still
in my portfolio it's gone through ups
and downs it's got lawsuits hanging over
it it's G all kinds of things that have
gone
through but my point is you can value a
company when is your project
du May 5th which is like a lifetime away
in the markets we're living in now
right who knows what the market will
look like on May 3rd hopefully you will
not have a 2008 crisis between now and
May 3rd but if it does happen you know
exactly what to do don't throw up your
hands the biggest number that's going to
shift is the equity risk premium I will
update my implied Equity risk premium on
May
1st and if it's really a crisis I'll
start updating every day if you want to
make it a direct input off my web page
you're welcome to equity risk gets
updated on its own it is the device that
you use to capture Market crisis the
price of risk goes up the value of
everything will go
down so about third
value at the start of 20
22 or actually somewhere in the middle
of 202 I don't know exactly when
September of 2022 remember inflation had
become this bogey man markets were
starting so I decided I wanted to Value
the S&P 500 because the market had been
down during
2022 and want to say is it did it drop
enough did it reflect so how you Val
stocks you take the expected cash flows
you get a risk adjust discount rate you
can think of the entire index like a
stock right this was actually a very
first valuation of the week where you
take the entire index you estimate the
cash flows so I'm going to set you up on
the questions I had in September of
20122 and then I'm going to ask a little
bit about where we are today and think
about the questions you would need to
ask today to Value the index one of my
first questions is when I was projecting
cash flows of the index I was using
analyst estimates of
ear and one of the you know at least in
September 2022 there was talk of a
recession around the corner and the
question is do my earnings numbers
reflect that recession can't answer it
right now but that's one of the
questions
second if you look at the cash that S&P
500 companies have returned historically
it was a very high percentage of
earnings but part of that came from
feeling secure about the earning stream
and low inflation my second question is
is it possible with inflation that
companies would return less cash because
they feel more uncertain about the
future third
you have no choice but to take a stand
in expected inflation because it's going
to play out both in your interest rates
and your growth rate so right now you
know what the interest rates are but
will inflation increase in September
2022 we had no clear sense whe we're
going to double digit inflation or
dropping back to 1 2% and as expected
inflation Rises not only will interest
rates rise but it also will push up the
equ so inflation is the central
character and it always is when
inflation DRS its ugly hat it always
becomes a central character so the
question is how do those numbers play
out so when I value the index I'm
basically taking the present value the
expected cash flows but the numbers are
coming from different places and it's my
job to ask those questions to make sure
they reflect so first question was about
earnings I you know I looked at in the
expected earnings at the start of every
year the through 2020 through at the
start of every month and you can see
that analyst had actually increased
their estimate of EXP earning there had
been a little pullback in the last few
weeks but analyst did not seem to be
worried about a recession in hindsight
they turned out to be right and the
economist turned out to be wrong but
analysts were not marking down earnings
dramatically and so they expected
earnings in 20123 and you can see over
time not much change what does that tell
me analysts don't seem to be building an
expectation of recession so if you're
valuing the company and you think
there's going to be a recession you have
to take their estimates and lower them
second I looked at the percentage of
earnings that us companies have returned
to their investors in the form of
dividends and stock BuyBacks and you you
look at that statistic it's clearly been
all the median across the entire period
was about
85% or 80 to 85% but by the time you got
to 2015 or 16 it was as high as
108% but in 2022 it was back to a normal
level at least based in the history if
this number had been 130% that's
something to worry about as well can
they maintain this cash returned over
time so I'm going of framing the
valuation here's what the final
valuation in September 2022 look like I
took the analyst estimates and I assumed
that they were underestimating
earnings by about 15% so I pushed in
that 15% drop collectively the companies
had returned 90.5% but I assumed that
going forward they'd become a little
more careful that they would return only
about 80% of their earning you see how
do you know I don't I'm making my best
judgment I did leave the the T bond rate
at the 4% saying the bulk of the
inflation effect has already played out
it's in my T bond rate and the equity
risk premium I used was 5% the average
since 2008 saying that's where we're
going to end up so think of this as
status quo valuation of the index and
the value that I got for the index with
these pretty owner assumptions was 3535
the index was at 3600 which is within 4%
and I said you know what I know there's
lots of talk about the index being in a
bubble and correcting I don't see it
because I lowered earnings by 15% raise
the equity risk but I'm pretty much
where the market is at least of
September of 2022 could I be wrong yeah
I know where where I can screw up I
could be off on the earnings or I can be
off on the t-bond rate so what I did was
I took variance of the risk-free rate
and earnings to see what the index would
look like at every level see the Shaded
the the shades don't show up but Any
number greater than 3693 would
essentially make the
index undervalued any number less than
so least in September 2022 the number
was about 55% under overvalued 45%
undervalued now whether you remember the
valuation of the week from the start of
the year I'd value the index of the
start of 2025 does anybody remember what
my base estimate value was I think was
5220 for the S&P 500 was at 58.81 making
it overvalued by 12 a
half% and there I actually ran a monard
simulation where I took my big
assumptions about earnings and growth
rates and risk premiums and I simulated
multiple values to see what percentage
of the time I got values greater than
58.81 which is where it was at and I
think at the start of this year it was
like 72% overv value 28% undervalue now
the index now is around 5550 it's
getting closer but remember the value
itself is also shifted so I have to
revalue the index I'm not a market timer
I don't act on my market valuation
because I really don't see what I bring
to the valuation that' be unique or
different I'm not a fed Watcher I don't
know where rates are going so I do it
just to kind of get a sense of where is
the market right now at the start of the
year it did look you know overpriced is
the way I would use it given all the
numbers and that was with Bas earnings
we had a recession on top and fears of
risk premiums going up the thing very
quickly becomes 15 20 25% so you get a
chance to revisit that valuation update
the numbers the T Bond rates have
clearly shifted since then put the
equity risk premiums in and see what you
get because if you listen to the noise
around you and part of the reason I
wrote that piece that some of you might
have read about you know globalization
and disruption coming to markets is I
was feeling a little unbalanced
and balance in the sense the world I
grew up in and I'm old and so it's the
world that you definitely grew up in as
well seems to be
changing under me right for much of my
life this this March towards
globalization seemed almost inexorable I
think the process kind of took a break
in 2008 but clearly we are entering a
new face and this is not just trumpet
and part of the reason I did is I'm sick
and tired of being reactive right every
day there's a another story I refused to
go on CNBC for the last two weeks simply
because of that they're going to ask me
about whatever the story of the day is
and what my instantaneous reaction what
does this do to the market I don't
know and it's just you know so one of
the reasons I whenever I'm on balance
two things help me one is to step back
and gain perspective how did we get
there and I think what you're seeing is
a playing out of those two large forces
we've seen for the last four days well
four years what four decades one is the
cresting of globalization as I call it I
think globalization peaked in
2008 what happened in 2008 because
globalization is essentially experts
saying trust us we know how to run the
world and 2008 was a reminder that they
really didn't know how to run the world
I don't think they've ever regained that
trust so much of what you've seen for
the last 17 years I would think of as a
blowback against globalization in all of
the things it's enriched
who's gained from
globalization China clearly has been the
biggest winner half the growth in much
of the last 20 years has come from China
right and of course it's not something
that they got put in their lab they work
for it they bu they they made themselves
a manufacturing upub they took the money
they built infrastructure and happened
accidentally second big winner from
globalization is global institutions
right I mean world bank and IMF are old
already been with us but they got
empowered by globalization then you add
the EU then you got in know agreements
like NAFTA it was this push towards you
know going spreading the power from
domestic to Global institution third was
experts who seem to have you know at
least a measure what the problems of the
world were what the solutions were and
they forums like Aspen and Davos where
they presented this to policy makers so
clearly and the fourth one is financial
Market
markets markets have become the Arbiters
of policy right you're a government you
try a policy markets don't like it you
walk it back very quickly because and
it's also enriched the cities that are
the centers of the market let's face it
New York Tokyo Frankfurt this has been a
good four decades not in terms of
livability but in terms of the wealth
and power that's
accumulated the winners have they been
losers it's got unth less China won and
it's true Global growth is not
necessarily zero SU game but I listed
the two parts of the world that have
lost the most Japan in 1995 was 17% of
world GDP you know what it is now
4% Europe was 26% of global GDP it's now
14% you say what about the US the US was
the outlier it actually increased GDP
we'll talk about why that might be from
the disruption
perspective big loser who else has lost
because of globalization
know so in terms of geographies you
know manufacturing jobs especially in
your now you take the number of
manufacturing jobs in the US peaked at
20 million 1979 it's down to 13 million
it's leveled
off because essentially manufacturing H
and this might be controversial but I
think democracy has been a casualty of
globalization and here's why what's the
biggest selling point for
democracy is you don't like the way your
government is run you will elect a
different party to run it right but
there is this perception that it doesn't
matter who runs your
country that there are Global forces
that are going to determine and I'm not
being a conspiracy theorist that is the
perception and among younger people the
perception is even stronger you talk to
people under the age of 35 the sense of
nothing I do is going to change this
because you know it's being set by and
that's Insidious it eats away if you
look at the economist measures this the
extend of democracy around the world
it's been dropping for the last 18 years
fewer people are under democracies now
than any time in the last two decades
and in my view the biggest problem with
globalization it's Advocates never
talked about the losers all win we all
win there's no of course there are
losers and when they raise their voices
what do you tell them learn to code how
insulting is this to ask a 55y old
factory worker to learn to
code so how is it played out well brexit
and I mean you're seeing it play out in
politics you're seeing it play out in
economics what I'm trying to say is
Trump and tariffs are not they're just a
symptom of a much bigger move against
globalization it's not going to end
here I mean we're approaching a decade
where you're going to see more domestic
with it mean we'll go back to the way we
in 197 no not at all that know that ship
is sailed but I have a feeling that many
of the things were used to with
globalization we're going to have to get
less used to because it's kind of coming
from this process so if you get a sense
read it because I also talk about
disruption and how it's come to
government and whether it can succeed I
mean let's face it the leaders there
were come from South America ja m in
Argentina na B and Salvador can you
bring that to the US you know that's
what basically doge is trying to do it's
a extraordinar dangerous project but
it's disruption coming to government so
you get a chance to read it because the
Tesla valuation is towards the end
of yes
good
e
e for